[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and new
month new q a i asked you guys on
twitter again like i usually do what you
wanted to know maybe i'll do it in a new
place next time but twitter seems to be
working pretty well
so these were your questions one of the
most popular ones will you ever start
vlogging uh i doubt it i don't think
that's uh i think it'll be pretty boring
because most of my vlogging would just
be behind the scenes of making the
videos that you guys already see i mean
maybe one or two behind-the-scenes
videos is kind of fun and neat and gives
you an idea of the behind-the-scenes
process but uh vlogging wouldn't be all
that exciting thoughts on the new mac
pro okay so technically there is a new
updated refresh version of the current
trashcan mac pro which if apple just
released that by itself and didn't say a
word about the new upcoming mac pro we'd
think they were insane but i'm assuming
you're talking about the new upcoming
2018 modular mac pro which there's a lot
of hype about now
which i am very excited for it's really
it's weird that you see that from apple
they usually never admit that they've
ever done anything wrong but they look
at the old mac pro and they say we
didn't get to update that enough and we
really wanted to we did that wrong the
next one will be better so that's
exciting for me plus seeing all the
drivers for the new nvidia cards coming
out available for mac os 10 the hype is
very real are your studio tour is going
to be limited to certain youtubers or
does anyone with the dope setup have a
shot at being featured so that's a great
question frank uh and i can expand so
the what's on series is brand new and in
general uh the first episode was a
studio tour with casey neistat but the
general idea is it would be a tour of
the tech that creative people and
creative things use to make what they do
happen so it's not just studio tours
it's not necessarily just a studio
sometimes it'll just be like a person
who does creative stuff and their
workspace or what they have on their
computer or their phone so to answer the
question no it won't just be youtubers
studio tours in fact the next episode
that we're planning
is not a youtuber at all but there will
be youtubers involved of course
collaborations are always fun with other
creators but obviously there's tons of
creative people that are outside the
world of youtube that would be fun to
showcase their tech here too pixel 2
wishlist so this first google pixel of
the past year was one of the phones that
i've used for the longest time because
it's a really complete experience it
nails pretty much all the pillars of a
great smartphone but my biggest problem
with it is actually it's not that big of
a problem but it's the design it's just
not that pretty and now there's all
these phones coming out like galaxy s8
and g6 and all plenty of others that
just have these gorgeous designs and
awesome displays as well so in theory
for pixel 2 i'd like to see it nail all
the same great pillars of a smartphone
with performance and stock android and
great camera but make it a lot prettier
are you excited for the samsung note 8
and do you think the brand can recover
from the note 7 problem this is
something i've thought about a lot like
people have been saying and there's two
sides of this equation where people have
been saying maybe they're just going to
cancel the whole note thing maybe
they're done with it but then the other
half is saying
people will just forget like they'll
come out with the note 8 and the whole
fiery explosion thing with note 7 will
be forgotten i tend to lean closer to
that side i definitely think note 8 is
going to happen and i think as they get
better and better and come out with more
phones you'll continue to forget the
things that samsung did that you didn't
like in the past including their
exploding phones but yeah i don't think
it'll be that big of a problem for
samsung it's funny because most of the a
lot of people i know actually who had a
note 7 were not really that concerned
because they're like oh my phone didn't
blow up it's fine i know the people who
did have a note 7 who did have their
phone blow up those people probably
won't buy a note8 but everyone else i
think will be pretty much okay with it
iphone 8 wishlist
how good can a phone camera get like
what is the ultimate stage where oems
are just like yeah this is the best we
got i like the first reply ask samsung
because they didn't upgrade the camera
in the s8
now i don't think there's ever going to
be like a maximum level where we reach
where we say all right we don't have to
make the cameras better anymore that's
kind of the beauty of technology is it's
just going to keep getting better and
better you might have thought like if
you saw today's best smartphones and
look back in 2011 and showed them the
phone they'd be like all right yeah
that's probably as good as we need to
get but tech keeps getting better and
better and more and more efficient i
think the interesting fun answer to that
question is if you look at what we had
in the nokia lumia what was that thing
nokia oh hold on i can google it the
1020. if you look at the lumia 1020 that
was a phone that went all in on the
camera it kind of did pretty well in
other areas of the phone it was a
windows phone whatever not a lot of
people bought it but it had a 41
megapixel camera xenon flash this was
the phone you buy if you want to take
lots of pictures so every once in a
while it'll be cool to see a phone like
that go all in on a spec uh there's
other phones that go all in on certain
other specs and they kind of make you
wonder are we pushing that limit too but
there will never ever be a point where
we say yeah we're done innovating here
have you ever critiqued yourself or
watched your older videos to improve
your style as a youtuber okay so you're
probably thinking of like me watching
like three four-year-old videos and then
thinking oh i can't believe i did that
that's so bad i'll get better at that no
i i watch videos that are like two or
three weeks old and feel the same way
you got to look at every video you make
as an opportunity to make something
better and as a youtuber i think my best
tip is to be your own biggest critic how
far do you see the clippers going this
year i think they'll lose in seven to
utah you think we're losing the first
round i'll bet you right now through
youtube we're not losing the first round
i see the clippers going
at least into the second round and our
ceiling would be western conference
finals again i feel like i said that
last year well brands continue to give
review units if you make videos similar
to the htc ultra video those who didn't
see it you should watch it the htc ultra
review was not a very nice one not a
very positive one but that's the whole
point of a review if there's something
that you shouldn't get then you should
know about how bad it is so a negative
review like that actually is a win for
everyone around it's a win for you guys
because you now know what not to buy it
might not seem like a win for htc on the
surface because people don't buy that
phone but when their next phone can use
improvements that they learn from the
reviews and when their next phone's way
better that also looks good for them and
on top of all that you now know for sure
that i'm not on like some chill side
with htc i'll clearly say when
something's wrong with a phone so when a
phone does come out and i praise it you
know it's good now i'm not saying make a
bad phone so that you can do better the
next year that's not a good strategy at
all just make the best thing you can but
bottom line is i think reviews are
really helpful in that way and that's
kind of the whole point you could spend
some marketing dollars on putting an ad
on tv with some superhero who's done ads
for other companies and it might get
seen by a lot of people but that guy
does ads for everything is it really
that effective or you could put the
phone in the hands of a person who has
an honest reputation and let them decide
for themselves if it's good or not and
if it turns out to be a good phone then
that's the easiest free good pr you can
get the best positive pr you can get is
just making a good product how about
that either way that's it for now thank
you for your questions i hope you
enjoyed the answers and uh feel free to
let me know in the comments below what
else you guys are thinking about we'll
chat about it i'll be down there lurking
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]